quelques accra pour pouvoir affronter le
vide et de l'après midi à varrault et
ses amis sont venus spécialement
d'espagne pour découvrir le carnaval
martiniquais
ils sont ravis de l'expérience dont on
connaît le canada et l'espagne mais on a
vu que ça n'a rien à voir c'est vraiment
très différent et il ya beaucoup de
couleurs beaucoup de bonne humeur mon
ambiance ont adoré ça va être surtout
faire un peu de tourisme
les matins et après l'après midi on va
descendre en ville voir les défilés
s'amuser le carnaval est un atout quand
on veut vendre les couleurs de la
martinique à l'office de tourisme du
centre sa fille et 21 ans
on se sert de ce patrimoine martiniquais
même si on est encore loin de
destinations comme trinidad où la
barbade qui en ont fait un produit
d'appel suis pas persuadé pour le moment
que ce sont les types de voyages mais en
tout cas c est très attractif pour ceux
qui le connaissent
quand ils ont déjà connu justement ces
séjours gras ils sont plus à même de
revenir ou bien la curiosité de voir un
petit peu de ce qui ce qu'ils n'ont pas
chez eux en tout cas dans les rues de
fort-de-france pour les visiteurs
l'esprit de la fête des comptes a chuté
et on repart avec des images et des
chansons plein la tête
c'est génial vous êtes pour tous bons
les vents les vivre ça c'est une
ambiance on se régale c'est vraiment
magique la couleur les gens sont
vraiment très sympa franchement c'est
que du bonheur tous nous l'ont promis
ils reviendront bientôt